[Music]
so we knew we were going to be dealing
with the blockade runner escaping from
the calamari ship we were cutting the
film together and my editor jay-bez
Olsen he said I think you need to see
one last moment with Darth Vader like I
think he needs to have like a badass
moment and we all felt the same way when
he mentioned this it was about four
months maybe from from release and so I
thought oh maybe we've missed it what
you need to do this and Kathy Kennedy
came in and jay-bez pitched this idea to
her and she really loved it the way I'd
like to work is you try and come up with
visual milestones of like well I'd love
to see this but I'd love to see this and
I'd love to see this I'm not sure how
they all connect and then what you do is
you create visuals of things that would
be great and then you try and find a way
of linking them all and we had three
days to shoot this sequence we just had
a brainstorming session like what's
what's cool shots little moments that
you know we feel we'd want to see in
here and and I like the idea I really
like the idea of them all being trapped
and that Vader's going to kill every
single one of them and that potentially
there anything that can escape is you
know the card that Princess Leia goes to
our TBC what's interesting about that
card actually is that there is no record
whatsoever of what that looks like
the only reference whatsoever is in
there the blu-ray of
a new hope and there's one close-up
where she starts to slide it in and we
just couldn't that's all we had to base
this card on and so it looked like they
had made a kind of credit card but with
also a disk in it like a gold disc the
props Department you know suggested a
few different ideas and I think they did
a really good job of trying to match
that perfectly I was highly aware of
where that prop was for the Death Star
plans and I took that Prop and and so
that I'm not saying where it is but I
have I have I did steal the Death Star
plans
I think the golden rule was not to let
Vader do anything you haven't seen or
established in the original trilogy and
so everything you sort of see him doing
down that corridor is pretty much
something from the previous films Greg
the DOP actually had Vader hold a real
lightsaber so in the sense that it would
when you turn it on true it would
actually light up and the problem was is
when you turn that on you can't see
radio you just see the lightsaber so we
put a light behind Vader and smoked up
the background so that as it was
synchronized as the as the lightsaber
turns on the background illuminates and
you see the silhouette because it feels
like the most iconic thing about later
is that silhouette and I guess it's sort
of represented in this sequence but with
the film we try to do a mixture of a
very classical very considered camera
moves you know that you saw in the
original trilogy and then sort of more
frenetic and how sort of embedded
photography and this sequence I really
like the way it sort of in intercuts
both styles and and and I think that
contrast is what used energetically
I knew I wanted to have a cameo in the
film because I love Star was so much but
I was saving it for the right thing and
it felt very appropriate to play the guy
who runs down the corridor and pulls the
handle because that way I get to survive
and therefore technically according to
Star Wars Canon I'm in so for a new hope
and I like to think that guy is kind of
the savior of the entire rebellion
really everything kind of the whole
original trilogy and and the prequels
and everything all comes through that
one person if it wasn't for him you know
there'd be no Star Wars and so I'm still
waiting for the action figure
[Music]
one that must are war story on digital
and blu-ray rated pg-13